et tout de suite tu l'invités politique
de la matinale magali forestier reçoit
florian philippot président des
patriotes
[Musique]
bonjour fois lors plus rien philippot
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france alors
on le voit le le président emmanuel
macron très réticents à mettre de
nouvelles mesures de restriction en
france uniquement le pas de calais qui
seraient confinés les week-ends à partir
de d'après demain ça va dans le bon sens
vous qui êtes contre toute restriction
sanitaires j'ai envie de dire enfin
c'est à dire enfin en peut-être qu'on va
sur une route qu'ils soient un peu moins
celle du délire dans lequel le laquelle
nous sommes enfermés depuis un an parce
que de toute façon il faut arrêter ces
confinement ces couvre feu etc
ça ne sert strictement rien enfin
maintenant on a la science pour le dire
ça a été démontrée eu des études très
sérieuses notamment l'université
américaine de stanford qui a démontré
que ça aggraver l'épidémie
mais si vous laissez pas parce qu'on
n'aura pas confiné un territoire qu'on
aura gagné quelque chose on aura
vraiment gagner quelque chose quand on
sera libre
quand on mettra fin à ce couvre-feu à
18h quand on mettra fin à la fermeture
de toutes les activités économiques des
restaurants de la culture et du reste et
quand nous retrouverons intégralement
toutes nos libertés qu on rouvrira tout
ça si vous voulez c'est pas à l'ordre du
jour et il est malheureusement on n'est
pas encore sorti de l'auberge
gabriel atallah a donné une idée de
calendrier pour lui retour à la normale
pas avant la mi-avril donner un cap aux
français ce que c'est important mais je
me méfie énormément de ce qu'il appelle
le retour d'ailleurs à une vie je le
cite quasi normal moi le quasi me fait
extrêmement peur et en fait quand on
connaît les projets du gouvernement qui
sont maintenant explicite ça veut dire
une vie où ce sera un peu plus rouvert
ce que veut pas dire d'ailleurs que leur
a pas encore des couvre-feux il y aura
toujours le masque y compris à
l'extérieur ce qui est une qui est une
absurdité totale mais en plus ils vont
nous inviter des qr codes partout à
flasher quand on rentrera dans un
restaurant il y aura le fameux pass
sanitaires sur lequel l'union européenne
et macron sont en train de travailler
c'est un vrai énorme problème éthique
d'énormes problèmes de liberté et
d'égalité entre les citoyens et de fin
d'ailleurs 2
le secret médical voilà donc si vous les
mois cette vie cette nouvelle normalité
comme on dit je n'en veux pas et je
crois qu'il faut continuer d'augmenter
la pression par des manifestations des
rassemblements comme nous le faisons
notamment tous les samedis la place
pierre laroque à paris sous les fenêtres
du ministère de la santé
c'est comme ça que le peuple se fait
entendre et c'est pas simplement en
disant qu'il n'est pas d'accord alors
des français qui seront d'accord avec
vous de plus en plus de français
adhèrent de moins en moins en tout cas à
ces restrictions il ya deux jours le
chef de l'état s'est rendu dans le
xviiie arrondissement de paris
il a pris un bain de foule au mépris
d'ailleurs des distanciation sanitaires
et un accueil vous allez le voir plutôt
tendue
[Musique]
florian philippot cette colère née des
français ce que vous la ressentez vous
en tant qu'élu mais évidemment
évidemment on voit bien d'ailleurs qu'il
ya je crois qu'il est sorti son agir 65%
des français maintenant contre le
confinement ça suffit pas facile il faut
il faut que les français soient un
peuple libre qui retrouve intégralement
toutes leurs libertés qu'on rouvre
toutes les activités qui sont fermés
qu'on rouvre les universités également
qu'on arrête ce délire collectif qu'on
arrête d'avoir à la place des
gouvernements le des gardes-chiourmes
d'hématomes prison qui considèrent leur
peuple comme des peuples assigné à
résidence sous cellule
ça suffit ça suffit totalement qu'il
travaille sur la prévention qu'ils
autorisent les médecins libéraux à
prescrire des traitements qui fonctionne
même si je sais que les seuls
traitements qui autorise les intéresse
le pouvoir ce sont ceux qui coûtent
extrêmement cher qu'à qui ramène de
l'argent à l'industrie pharmaceutique
pourtant il ya des traitements qui coûte
pas un rond mais qui sont extrêmement
efficaces ivermectine et et tant
d'autres il faut les autoriser il faut
arrêter fermer des lits à l'hôpital mais
il faut libérer complètement le pays je
vois le texas qui le fais je vois le
mississippi qui le fait je vois des pays
qui l'ont fait depuis longtemps comme
l'inde etc et qui ont beaucoup moins de
morts par habitant que la france mais
qui ont arrêté de détruire leur pays de
détruire les métiers un art de vivre et
la liberté
ce retour quasi normal c'était par
gabriel a taillé pour vous il passe par
une campagne de vaccination réussi non
mais encore une fois ils n'auront pas en
tête un retour à la vie normale ils ont
un retour en tête aller vers un monde
inconnu vers un monde de surveillance
numérique de contrôle par pas sanitaire
qr code vous voulez ça comme monde
voulait que quand vous rentrez dans un
cinéma un festival un restaurant quand
vous prenez le métro ou le train on vous
demande de flasher quelque chose vous
demandons de montrer un pass qui montre
que vous êtes vacciné que vous avez fait
un test il ya moins de 48 heures c'est
le monde vraiment qu'on veut moi je ne
veux pas de ce monde là où on serait en
permanence sous masque par ailleurs non
je un monde où on s'occupe normalement
des malades on les traite on autorise
les médecins à prescrire on arrête de
détruire sa cage et l'hôpital public
comme on l'a fait depuis des décennies
mais je ne veux pas de ce monde où on
serait pousse forcément vacciner tester
le masque est plastifié plexiglas ise qr
code is et passe talitha risée etc
je veux pas de ce monde là c'est un
monde profondément inhumain est infernal
là le vaccin pour ceux qui le souhaitent
mais moi je suis pour une liberté totale
vaccinale y compris pour ceux qui ne
veulent pas se faire il faut néanmoins
protéger les personnes qui sont un
fragile 400 morts en moyenne tous les
jours florian philippot cesserait ce
monde normal dont vous parlez une
passerait par quoi pour protéger ces
personnes là bas c'est à dire qu'on
aurait pas 400 morts par jour si on
soigner les gens si on autorisait les
traitements qui sont autorisées ailleurs
va aller voir en inde il en conçoit
moins onze fois moins de morts par
l'habitant que la france pourtant un
pays qui est pas considérée comme un
pays richissime en tout cas par peu par
habitant parce qu'il autorise depuis
très longtemps l'ivermectine est d'aider
d'autres et d'autres d'autres soins
voilà donc ciblé il faut desserrer cet
étau incompréhensible sur les
traitements et il faut prendre soin des
personnes dont on sait qu'elles sont
vulnérables
on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est une maladie
qui tue globalement trop toujours trop
mais qui tue pas non plus par la peste
noire si vous n'avez pas des monceaux de
cadavres dans les rues il sait pas ça on
sait que ça q des gens qui ont en
moyenne ont 81 ans
voilà donc il faut en prendre soin il
faut renforcer les liens à l'hôpital il
faut faire de la prévention avec la
vitamine d la vitamine c sas a été
recommandé par les autorités médicales
mais jamais vers on n'en parle jamais
macro on en parle
ce qui les intéresse c'est le vaccin le
passe à lithaire les confinements où les
couvre-feux et évidemment les
médicaments comme les anticorps
monoclonaux qui coûte 2000 euros ce qui
est alors que leur efficacité tout à
fait disputer là il ya un énorme
problème il ya des problèmes derrière de
conflit d'intérêts les médecins
généralistes sont aussi en colère mg
france a publié un communiqué hier pour
dénoncer la stratégie de vaccination des
autorités sanitaires il refuse d'être
tenu pour responsable de cette lenteur
regarder mg france
les autorités sanitaires de tenter de
masquer les retards observés dans cette
campagne est de chercher un bouc
émissaire qui serait responsable de ces
retards
les médecins généralistes qui sont comme
chaque fois au rendez-vous exige la mise
à disposition immédiate de toutes les
doses dont il estime avoir besoin
presqu'un quart des deux seulement
d'astrazeneca ont été distribués l'an
riscle et les trois quarts et c'est
vraiment nous ces vaccins sont passés ce
que leur colère est légitime selon vous
lourdement quelque chose d'impossible à
réaliser parce que le gouvernement
français est passé par l'union
européenne pour les commandes de vaccin
à en l'ignorant peine comme tout ce
qu'elle touche elle le transforme en
double si vous voulez être incapable de
faire ça donc en réalité c'est un fiasco
général de l'union européenne cette
affaire alors oui moi je suis pour la
liberté vaccinale je vous disais à
l'instant donc je suis pour que ceux qui
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner puisse
ne pas l'être sans être sans devenir
demain des sous citoyens mais en même
temps ceux qui veulent être vaccinés je
comprends qu'ils aient envie de l'être
rapidement mais ils peuvent pas parce
que le gouvernement français est passé
par l'union européenne par l'idéologie
européiste voilà on en paye le prix
aujourd'hui voilà à force d'être un pays
qui renonce à sa souveraineté en tous
domaines
bon on peut plus rien faire une dernière
question florian philippot cette enquête
ifop qui révèle que les lycéens rejette
majoritairement la laïcité à la
française
on va voir d'ailleurs les chiffres 52 %
des lycéens favorables aux au port de
signes religieux dans les lycées publics
49% ne voit pas d'inconvénient à ce que
les agents publics affichent leurs
convictions religieuses et 38 % des
lycéens se disent favorables à une loi
qui autoriserait le port du burkini
est-ce que ce sondage vous étonne pas
vraiment pas vraiment je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'il est le
reflet la mondialisation sauvage
il ya deux choses dans la mondialisation
il ya un l'immigration massive et vous
voyez ces chiffres là chez les jeunes de
confession musulmane c'est pas les
chiffres que vous annoncez c'était
plutôt des 80 90 % parce que l'ifop
donne le détail
et puis l'autre jambe de la
mondialisation sauvage c'est
l'américanisation est en fait beaucoup d
une nouvelle génération de baigne dans
un bain culturel totalement anglo saxons
américain qui correspond à ça mais qui
ne correspond pas à la laïcité à la
française
il correspond plutôt à ce modèle
communautariste voilà donc
je suis pas vraiment étonné et si la
france
rapidement on lui reprend papier et bien
la dérive ne sera plus croissante
merci beaucoup florian philippot d'avoir
répondu en direct ce matin à nos
questions sur rt france